il
[Musique]
ces images c'est moi qui les ai faites
je suis pompier depuis 15 ans et
j'habite ici en occitanie dans le sud de
la france
à 18 ans j'ai intégré la brigade des
sapeurs-pompiers de paris
cinq ans après je reviens dans mon sud
natal mais je deviens pompiers
professionnels je suis heureux de
retrouver ma région de vivre de ma
passion et je me spécialise comme
plongeur et nageurs sauveteurs
vous le reconnaissez tous c'est un poste
de secours de plage qui passent des
journées entières un période estivale à
retrouver les parents d'enfants perdus à
retrouver les enfants de parents perdus
à surveiller les baignades mais aussi à
traiter les piqûres de méduses et bien
sûr les brûlures le de méduses et les
piqûres de vivre un soir à la fermeture
du poste
je commence à ramasser une bouteille en
plastique puis deux puis trois je
commence à ramasser un emballage de
goûter puis deux puis trois j'observe
les mégots planté dans le sable en guise
de cendriers où on pouvait même deviner
l'emplacement d'un serviettes de l'après
midi les jours s'enchaînent et je fais
le constat que malheureusement sous
l'eau c'est la même chose on tombe plus
facilement sur des déchets que sur une
bête daurade ou un bol ouf
là je commence à m'inquiéter
mais quand j'en parlais en caserne dans
mon travail le soir avec mes amis
j'entendais toujours les mêmes
réflexions benoît on n'est pas des
écolos benoît c'est les pêcheurs benoît
c'est les touristes c'est comme ça
faut-il être un militant écologiste pour
se sentir concerné par l'état de notre
environnement
faut-il faut-il se sentir faut-il être
contre le tourisme en pour limiter la
pollution plastique sur notre littoral
moi en tout cas
il fallait que j'agisse et que je montre
que tout le monde à ce niveau pourrait
être concerné par ce sujet alors j'ai
décidé comme de m'équiper d'une caméra
et de mon smartphone et de prendre en
photo les déchets sur la page et le bel
emballage de chips qui fait entre deux
eaux et la multitude de déchets qui se
trouve au fond de l'eau mon but c'est de
le publier sur les réseaux sociaux de
montrer l'impact des comportements des
uns et des autres sur nos fonds marins
est d'abord sur nos belles plages
j'intitule sa project rescue au cern
très vite le nombre d'abonnés se
multiplient en quelques mois sur les
réseaux sociaux j'obtiens 2000 abonnés
je suis contacté par de prestigieuses
ong un jour même je reçois une
invitation par l'ancien ministre qui à
la tête d'une fondation pour participer
à une conférence conférence au grand rex
à paris
une fois encore sinon ng mondialement
connu qui m'évite apam à marseille pour
me recruter mais qui selon moi affiche
des idées qui dévie divise et qui ne
fédère pas souvenez vous de mes amis qui
sont très sceptiques et qui ne se
sentent pas concernés par le sujet est
bien pour moi c'était eux - défi au delà
de faire prendre conscience de l'état
des rivières des maires et des os des
océans je comprenais le défi de faire
changer les mentalités de donner un
nouveau regard sur le respect de
l'environnement
tout simplement montrant que tout le
monde peut être concerné sans parler
d'écologie de militantisme mais
simplement d'écocitoyenneté alors je
crée une association de loi 1901 à but
non lucratif l'intérêt général à la
touche bien française project rescue aux
séances
puis je décide de passer à l'étape
supérieure
un jour après un fameux coup de mer qui
amène énormément de déchet je décide de
créer un premier événement sur les
réseaux sociaux pour aller nettoyer une
plage et il ya cinq ans avec ma voiture
ensablé a distribué des sacs poubelles à
mes amis des réseaux sociaux on me
prenait vraiment pour un fou mais comme
vous le savez après coup de mer qui
amène énormément de déchet enchevêtrés
dans le bois flotté dans le sable il me
fallait vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de
main d'oeuvre
alors d'après vous comment on fait venir
ou le v1 jeunes de 18 20 ans pourra lui
faire nettoyer une plage un samedi matin
et dirais même plus aux jeunes de 18 20
ans qui est sortie le samedi soir pour
une soirée plutôt bien arrosée c'est moi
perso à 18 ans il me fallait vraiment
une super bonne raison pour faire lever
du lit
alors j'ai réfléchi à partir de mon
exemple faire remplir des sacs de
déchets avec un serrage de main merci
vous avez nettoyer la plage merci c'est
super et un mois après hop autant de
déchets sur la plage faire remplir des
sacs d'ordures en faisant des leçons de
morale sur la surconsommation mais le
zéro déchet pas très motivant tout ça et
pour tout vous avouer pas très motivant
pour moi non plus je me souviens de mon
père de mon grand père avec qui ont
passé des journées entières à la pêche
et qui parfois nous faisait ramené à la
poubelle de la maison des déchets qui
était même pas les nôtres
on passait tellement une bonne journée
alors l'imaginé une action agréable une
action intergénérationnelle du café et
des croissants de la musique parfois
même des chevaux
vous imaginez un peu le tableau pour moi
la convivialité
c'est la clé pour motiver mais comme je
voulais 10 après un coup de mer ou en
période d'inondations on arrive à
retrouver des pneus des frigos un essieu
de voiture il ya pas longtemps
des panneaux du mobilier des carcasses
de bateaux et là c'est une équipe
entière de rugby qu'il me fallait alors
d'après vous comment faire venir une
équipe de rugby sur nettoyage de plage
si toutefois ils n'ont pas macho
week-end une idée mais vous leur dites
qu'il y aura une dégustation de bière
après la collecte et à votre avis
comment faire venir toute une école
d'étudiants infirmières pour un
nettoyage de plage et bien sûr si
toutefois ils n'ont pas cours le
week-end
vous leur dites simplement que les
rugbymen seront présents alors là on
arrive à faire venir jusqu'à 800
personnes sur les plages et là on arrive
à collecter plusieurs tonnes en deux
heures en moins de deux ans nous avons
connecté collecté plus de 55000 kg de
déchets sauvages sur les plages sa
machine uniquement avait nommé
simplement en fédérant et en montrant
que tout le monde peut être concerné
dans mon métier pompiers pour remplir
une mission combattre un incendie
nouveau nous devons travailler en équipe
et nous devons avoir des renforts
nous devons nous organiser et c'est ce
modèle que j'ai pris les renforts c'est
vous l'organisation vous la connaissez
et le résultat ce sont les tonnes de
déchets collectés mais vous allez me
dire collecter c'est bien mais hop dans
un mois un nouveau coup de mer est
toujours autant de déchets sur la plage
c'est une histoire sans fin en disant
j'ai vu l'état de notre littoral s'est
dégradée d'une façon dramatique
vous imaginez la situation dans dix ans
de plus si nous n'agissons pas ma fille
à peine un an
je ne peux pas m'imaginer l'amener sur
une plage couverte de déchets et de
mégots ou de la faire plonger dans des
formats rues désertées de toute vie ou
le plastique serait roi alors vraiment
une histoire sans fin
après cette première étape de
mobilisation
j'ai développé un second taxes dans
l'association la sensibilisation par la
sensibilisation à l'écologie la
sensibilisation à l'écocitoyenneté le
bon sens
puis l'action je me souviendrai toujours
de ma première fête matinée face à des
enfants de même pas 10 ans où je leur
montrais les déchets que j'avais
collectées sur la plage avec les élèves
j'ai choisi d'être simple pas
moralisateur et ça fonctionne
aujourd'hui nous avons diplômés
plusieurs milliers d'enfants sauveteurs
des océans car je suis persuadé qu'on
enfants sensibilisés ça deviendra un
adulte responsable et que la jeunesse de
demain sera une génération océans dans
mon métier de pompier pour remplir les
missions combattre un incendie
nous devons s'adapter et trouver de
nouveaux moyens pour atteindre nos
objectifs et des nouveaux moyens j'en ai
trouvé ce en récoltant plusieurs tonnes
de filets de pêche auprès de mes amis
pêcheurs que j'ai eu l'idée de contacter
une école de mode mondialement connu
pour faire des robes à partir de ses
filets et ça a fonctionné aujourd'hui
des écoles de jakarta de colomb pour
nous contacter pour continuer projet
pourquoi tout simplement grâce à cet
angle de la mode je voulais toucher un
autre type de public
après la mode vient cracher sur une
nouvelle cible à sensibiliser le sport
nous sommes partenaires des équipes de
sport de haut-niveau avec qui nous
organisons deux avec qui nous organisons
des actions éco citoyennes tout le long
de l'année
rien de vaut mieux de voir le rugbyman
de deux mètres qui se baissent qui
ramasse les déchets et qui le jette à la
poubelle
nous avons même présenté projet reste
sert à un footballeur champion du monde
qui joue en équipe de barcelone et qui
joue et il ya encore quelques mois la
psycho de madrid
ce que vous voyez qui sait
si ces champions le faut bien sûr que la
jeunesse qui les admirent seront touchés
après la mode le sport le monde du
cinéma
il ya une expression qui dit que le
monde du cinéma c'est le miroir du monde
nous avons eu la chance incroyable de
représenter project rescue océans sur
les marches du palais pendant le
festival de cannes c'est chic non nous
avons appelé parrainé par un acteur
réalisateur à nos débuts nous recevons
des soutiens et des partages de diverses
personnalités
nous avons même rencontré un groupe de
rock à plusieurs reprises
imaginez la puissance et l'impact de ces
personnes qui partagent et relais nos
messages de sensibilisation
ce sont des vecteurs fabuleux et tout ça
pour moi sert à changer les mentalités
tout simplement à moins de 5 ans nous
avons développé trois antennes à
marseille à paris et à toulouse
nous rassemblons plus de 45 nationalités
nous sommes implantés dans 11 pays
ben ali qatar hawaï haïti ça représente
plusieurs milliers de bénévoles à moins
de 5 ans j'ai porté j'ai poussé les
portes de l'unesco pour proposer des
solutions simples et concrètes pour
améliorer l'état de nos océans et de
notre planète nous avons même été reçus
par la convention cadre de l'onu sur le
changement climatique où nous avons été
cités comme association leadership
qu'est-ce que cela prouve mais juste
avant juste avant rappelez-vous d'où ces
partis une simple photo sur les réseaux
sociaux ça qu'est-ce que cela prouve
pour peu qu'on en ait pu vous toucher
vous sensibilisez vous être secouriste
de la planète
c'est à portée de vos mais alors je vous
propose de prendre quelques instants
quelques instants avec vous même ici
maintenant
là cette salle quelques instants pour
vous engager à collecter 1 déchets
sauvages par jour à le faire savoir
autour de vous et pourquoi pas à l'aide
des réseaux sociaux
si vous êtes prêts attachez encore mieux
demandez à votre voisin où voisinent
d'attaché ce ruban rouge
ça y est
ses coûts
je
ça y est vous est pris
une fois que ce bracelet attaché à votre
poignet une fois qu'il est attaché à ce
poignet montre l'exemple
c'est le seul moyen persie
[Applaudissements]